how many people here worse with corsola
so I see a few on the desktop sealer
okay on other languages python I don't
see anyone
C++ okay good think we're studying how
you're having are you having good final
and they see you like it good
I'm here to disappoint you okay
for those that do not know me I have
been working on performance for more
than 10 years like I have used like
every single CPU kind of stuff that you
can think about from very very low power
stuff to high powers GPU so if you have
any question outside from what I'm going
to talk about today which is in a sense
c-sharp only but most of the these
techniques work on other languages
that's why I'm asking this kind of this
kind of stuff it's pretty interesting
for me so just get me around in around
the corner and and just ask me whatever
you want today what we are going to talk
about is how you deal with the cases
when you actually need to go on
high-performance because let's face it
most of the time we just don't care as
long as it works as long as it's in it's
in budget we're fine so let's say that
on Monday your boss comes and says hey
you know we have to nuke this new client
and we actually have to be able to deal
with 20 billion operations per day I'm
gonna wait a little bit so you actually
sink on that but not number which looks
like this how many of you have had the
luck to actually deal with this kind of
stuff okay we have a few so big honor
probably on the three or five companies
that actually have to deal with
such amount of of requests so let's say
this is a big number this is something
that it's for most uses and purposes
intractable to your mind so let's let's
start to work around this a little bit
so we're talking about twenty billion
operations so if we look at like okay
let's assume that this is uniformly
distributed which usually is not but
let's assume for a probit that's Ram 800
million yeah more or less
give or take but you know what this is
going so we are going to try to narrow
this down as much as possible so on
sixty and sixty minutes how much we have
to deal with thirty million it doesn't
look that bad
at least not that's bad that there's
twenty billion when you started when we
want when we go to a minute this is
actually a tractable number this is a
number that you can get your ran at your
mind around and you can think of it so
what would you typically do you are if
you have to deal with this you will just
go and spin up a plasterer typical stuff
you go you build your kubernetes your
you deploy and you're done because this
is roughly five k6k operations per node
which is with today tools
totally doable the thing is that for
most state of death of the software
today even though there had been a lot
of strides that I that's why I asked
first
if anyone have been using concealer
because their system talks of actually
serving request on corsola and the new
asp.net has really go down but real hard
at some point like five years ago in
your with your highest end server this
actually was the task of M busy you are
you are not going to go even higher than
this because that was about it
just to serve a static stuff so
typically this is how we usually solve
it with within in the usual industry
like we just keep spinning stuff like
because this is a number that is simple
if you have a 550 operations per node it
looks fine
I know many many many enterprise
applications there are even in numbers
lower than 10 and they are supposed to
be high performance so just to give you
a sense of what the very first number
that we look like 55k operations per no
means is roughly around 5 milliseconds
preparation per second per node game
developers have been working with even
worse budgets to actually make games so
this is actually quite high everything
that we are everything that we are doing
today has been solving in one case and
another had to be solved to actually
make games so if we are not able to
solve this kind this kind of problem
with like our bare hands we're screwed
really
so when optimizing it's like you can
have like these three levels in one
level you have like okay this is piece
of cake this is this something that that
a junior developer can knock out in in a
weekend if you're not able to achieve
600 requests per second per node in a
weekend you are doing it wrong but then
the typical enterprise software and most
most like 90% or a if you will use
Pareto the 80% software it's around this
kind of this level you have operations
there are times seeing that I really
really time-sensitive but most of them
are not so if you deal with those and
you are able to achieve a sustained six
thousand requests per second per node
you are like in a very very good place
because
you are not burning money which is good
and you're also able to serve with a
less than five millisecond latency if
you are like right to their to the
server but I particularly work on a
particular field which is database
engine design if you have to serve this
number I have to live in this number
because you're not going to like ask me
for that record you're probably going to
ask me for like oh yes this is the user
and this is the other thing and now give
me the profile and now so probably I
have to serve around four to seven
requests before you can actually finish
your operation so this is the kind of
level that is baseline for anyone
working in the database industry and you
actually have to work higher than this
but you can think of and you can think
about this from your own perspective
noting the database protect the
perspective but for your own system
perspective and you can think of it like
there's metrics that we know it's like
that if you are in the if your target is
one second of latency we are not talking
about throughput here we are talking
about latency you're in one second you
can you can knock any anything in our
weekend that can do stuff in soup second
okay but when you go when you go lower
that you have to keep a budget of $110
pretty fast so today's talk this is one
of the important things that about
today's talk we are not going to talk
about how to make performance is a big
field okay there are life things that
you can actually go to the books and
it's there if you if you go around
interrupts cause you know that
allocations are the major source of
performance
like mayor if if you have a software
that is misbehaving the very first thing
that you are going to look at is
allocations period this is like the
sanity check this list is like the
sanity checks but I want you to watch a
two in particular which is allocations
are major source of performance issues
which is something that we know already
but also a tidbit that is probably not
so known in in the community which is
value types are subject to a special
sets of optimizations
but the shyest is not compiler this is
important this is this is what the
entire talk is going to be around at the
VN like the introduction stuff so
there's other interesting things like
that happen happen at the moment of a
meeting code that the just-in-time
compiler does and one of the most
important for this is that it's able to
constant propagate stuff so if you have
a constant and it just this time say a
this is a constant now now it can
propagate it up over the stack as long
as there is no a method call there's no
a mythical and the other side it can
eliminate code if you're an if the
condition is false and you're not going
to enter it because you left it there
for like the bug purposes it's not gonna
end in release code because it's going
to be eliminated so if you're serious
about performance my recommendation is
get these two books you don't know you
don't need anything more than that the
first one is a real real real good book
about the specifics of how to actually
do benchmarking because if you're
measuring wrong you are taking the wrong
decisions period this one product net
benchmarking from Andrea Kingston is
going to be available in September
I know it's good because I read the
draft the other one is about dealing
with memory like understanding the
memory model of dotnet and actually work
around from it so that that one is
already am i available
so when you start working with
performance it's pretty easy to just go
for the for the very small things and
not figure out that pain there's
actually a good in here so let's not go
for the tree let's go for the big thing
so we devised a way to actually
characterize internally how what what
kind of problem we are dealing about
think about the potato you can take the
product distribution 8020 which is like
the typical how you think about the
Pareto distribution so let's say that
you have the 80/20 now square it this
means that if you think about it if 80%
in the at the first level 80 percent of
the resources consumed 20 percent of the
of the code is caused by 20 percent of
the code now if you square it
essentially what you have is like that 4
percent of the code actually is
responsible for 60% of the resources and
if you do it again you go you go cubic
now eight point zero point eight percent
of the code consumes have the resources
and this is not a rule this is something
that we found in practice I deal with
the zero point eight usually because
it's too costly to actually go to the
four zero to the 4 and to the 20 and I'm
going to show you why but the idea here
is that if you say I'm you say I'm this
is a potato problem I know that we are
talking about next mayor version period
if I know if this is operator square
then I'm talking something that probably
it's a high-risk task it's something
that you will not do like in a weakened
but if I talk about these operators who
a operator cubic thing then okay this
makes sense I probably can do this and
can figure out how to make it work in a
few weeks
but this is because we have been in the
process of optimizing for years so
essentially I'm looking for the 1% like
having today having a Micro preemies
ation level which is but I talk about it
to cure sorry
cubic is essentially I'm looking for 1%
2% if I get that 10%
it's like mere so that they are here if
when you go up in the scale what you are
looking actually is typically the
network i/o architecture algorithmic big
algorithm a stuff like if you are using
a and forth into the fourth algorithm
instead you could do that with linear or
sub linear like big stuff like if you
change this you are looking for more
than 20 X performance improvement if not
you are not going to do it unless
obviously you are just starting with
with the process in which case it's
always easier to get on top because it's
where the actual payoff will be it's not
uncommon if you if you go to a new
software that has been optimized before
if you go I where I go hunting in a
new--it's a new clients come in where I
go hunting
I go hunt in there why because probably
it's highly probable that I can find
stuff that I can still fix on this level
that is not high cost and it have an
insane performance improvement we are
talking that a fixed there can get you 6
TX 78109 is that kind of improvement if
you're selling for instance by course it
actually gonna kill your business model
so the second level is where you are
dealing with like small variations and
and and the algorithmic time so probably
you are not moving from the from you
probably are going to get like you have
an N and you go sub linear
or even between the sub Lanier's not
also Blin ears are created equal so this
is this is what they kinda kind of stuff
that we learn in complexity at the
University like oh yes I have this big
huge at this beautiful algorithm that
can do like sub linear stuff but hey my
size my world is so small that even the
linear one is going to be faster and
then it's the world and the world of my
optimization that's where the boudu
happens this is what this talk is about
so the very first thing that you have to
know from the start is if you have to
microbe demise make sure there's no
option because it's a one-way road when
you start in the Micro preemies station
your code is gonna start to looking way
differently to what it looked before and
it also means that you have to be very
careful how you change it a long time so
the people that is allowed to talk to
touch that code it's going to get
reduced it pretty fast to real it to
real to the to the real senior staff so
this is like last resort is like I don't
have any other way so I go this route
but because you're here to see something
that you can find in books let's talk
about this so this is true story
everything that I'm going to tell you
from now on is based on a particular of
the word that we did for a particular
product so everything is is time I'm
going to start introduction where we
were and where we needed to go so
obviously what I would do from the from
the get-go is let's go hand for the bed
and for the bottlenecks so we started
with raping the B bottlenecks at the two
at the version mayor version two so we
figure out a you know after some
optimizing I'm figuring out we actually
figure out okay the single right lock
and the lack of batching operations
which is architectural stuff this is
something that you are not able to
change like from even even in a
this is this is mayor stuff this is
stuff that if you have to do with it you
have to create an entire new mayor
version for you also the interrupts cast
there was like this amount of decisions
that were made on the initial on the des
planning style on the planning moment of
the product you end up there so this is
not something any any of these problems
is something that you can fix on to zero
so you have to start thinking okay how
do I deal with all this so essentially
this is what we did we figured out hey
you know we don't have operate batching
operations okay we build like an entire
engine that is able to batch operations
we have to deal with the interrupts cost
we build an an entire database storage
build on c-sharp just to avoid danger up
the hashing we implemented like a we
have a huge form of very specific
hashing functions specifically for each
use and all of them instead of going to
the optimized C C++ code we they're just
built entirely in c-sharp to avoid all
the interrupts so we end up in three
zero and in three zero hey use newsflash
new bottlenecks so it's not like okay
yes I get rid of these ones but now
those ones become like huge so just to
give an idea just dealing with those
kind we we just get rid of 10x which
means that when you needed four
computers now you can do the same with
half so when we start at four zero now
another my aversion to actually deal
with all the other stuff we did a lot of
stuff just to get just to get rid of
those bottlenecks and the most
interesting thing here is that we
actually had to go unmanaged
we have to actually have to deal with
the with the memory itself and when you
start on that road is when I say it's a
way it's an only way so if you go there
you are not coming back period so
we went we went by the book it is this
is a kind of thing that you if you're
optimizing you will do period so we
decided to tackle these three just d3
that then time Mayor version was about
tackling this we ended up doing some
some work on the others but this is boss
about this three this this is the mayor
thing that you were you are going to do
okay we took two years it's not like
something that you can do we are looking
forward two years to actually build a
mayor and marry a Persian so we started
with a very simple assumption is with we
said request hey
what application doesn't do that it's
typical so it is typical so the
interesting thing about requisites is
they start in the end there's stateless
kind of so the interesting thing is when
you start to look into these requests so
you figure out hey you know string
allocations to nominate and dominate big
like we're talking about gigabytes per
minute so when you look at and you start
disagree eight in all this you figure
out okay collections like Arabic a huge
a huge issue you look at generation
general reclaim able so you build a
subject and you return it that's cost
don't don't don't get me started with a
sink
I think it's cool yeah it's cool it's
performance is real real bad if you're
an insensitive goal getting out from the
sink machinery it's like the best thing
that you can do it's like you are going
to get a boost children also you have to
be very very careful with the lambda
capture context we have lambdas
everywhere because lambdas are cool yeah
but the contest when you have to capture
the context you're allocating and if
you're allocating like in a loop a
million operations in a minute that
adapts pretty fast
so we decided okay we are going to get
rid of allocations we are going to get
rid with we are going to create our own
string and okay a string representation
because we were already dealing with and
manage stuff so we couldn't fake it now
you have a spun still if you are dealing
with and manage that stuff span is not
that good so the thing is we went all
this road back in 2015 with expand
didn't exist anymore but what I'm going
to show you is how you can build spans
like spun like abstractions in raw C
sharp without needing the just-in-time
optimizations specifically so let's
think about what we what we created at
the time it was the byte string if you
if you look at the at the wrong
implementation of our new span it looks
more on an ax string it more or less
look like this you have some flags in
our case because we needed we needed to
write down some stuff about that
particular string you have the length
you have your pointer and you have the
actual size okay so the length of the
string and the size of the memory that
is bucking it up this is this is very
specific to our use case which is we
reserved an amount of memory and if it's
rings we don't we don't go creating and
get it getting you memory for it so
obviously this sounds familiar because
if you look at it this is a span which
is essentially a pointer and its length
but the problem is that you cannot do
this at least not legally this is not
legal C sharp so the problem with this
is you can see you can see the the
moshav are in there which is a struct
that's
thirty six bytes if on every method code
that I do I have to copy 36 bytes that's
huge right it erupts pretty fast let's
do the math a million of those 35 35
bytes that means 35 megabytes per
million calls which is big and that's
assuming a single parameter but you know
anyone anyone that comes from the C++ or
C or C background knows how to fix this
actually we are we are told how to fix
this in university which is there's no
problem in computer science that can be
so if we if we don't add another level
of indirection the problem is the what
kind of interaction that you are adding
okay some of them are intractable so
essentially what we did was this okay we
have a back in storage we have like this
huge array of memory and this is a
pointer to that particular case so the
question is how much do you think this
cost anyone to amble how much I do it do
I get that 16 bytes here no no 16 do I
get a grenade yes it bites so this
pointer is the size of an integral and
because this pointer is the size of an
interior we can do a very simple
exercise which is a how much does
passing a by string as a parameter cost
so we essentially did this sorry an
eternal along so we are doing something
like this we are comparing it with long
which is essentially has the same size
we wanted to know if that is the same
thing so essentially we took the path at
the very root of the byte stream
which is essentially the backing store
which is a pointer angry execute this
let's start with the long this is how a
long call looks like
so essentially you move the stock you
move that to the RCA you move the
location to the RCX you call the using
long you move the results back to the
RCX you execute a right line data knob I
don't know where it comes from you now
work again with with the stack and then
you return this is your method call
let's do the same thing for our pointer
let's do the same thing for our buy
stream now we got the move we got the
call we got the copy to to the parameter
list again we got our call and we've got
our result we're coming back so anyone
can guess which one is the byte string I
don't know you but I know that I can't
why because of this this is the only
difference so
I think at this moment that now you're
standing to endure sound and to know
where this is going but wait wait for it
let's talk about that different and
entirely different concept that comes
from other languages not C sharp which
is meta programming for those that come
from the C++ behavior sorry I'm a C++
background you have seen this kind of
stuff before
those are marker interfaces you're
saying okay this is a trait you're going
to interface and you'll be less struct
out of that interface so let's let's
think about it if we have a marker a we
know that we can call anything that is
defined already in the interface and we
if we got a marker J we also can do the
same thing in this case this also is an
empty interface but the interesting
thing is that we can write something
like this where our method is going to
take a type which is actually an
interface but because the implementation
of these guys is a struct and I don't
know if you remember from the very first
slides what happened with starts with
value types they are subject to special
optimizations because this what it
happens if if we call this method which
is generic method marker a1 0 what we
actually get is something like this and
because you know you remember from the
second slide which says code elimination
it just happened that if you are
equaling one thing that is equal to the
other thing it goes out because it's
true
so this is the only code that gets a
minute what happens if we do the other
way around if we say ok this is marker J
we have a type which is also we know
it's different so now it happens like
this so this is the code a minute
but you know why metaprogramming is good
because we have been using it
successfully for years so it's not
something that you say ok now this is
this is new stuff no no this has been
here for 20 years it just that we didn't
have the facilities to actually use it
so why we would use these kind of
facilities because we can get rid of
beautiful codes which are absolutely
expensive because we can tailor our
algorithms just for the case they were
built they were being called for so if I
know this algorithm this location is
going to be used in this way I can
instruct the run time this is how I want
this algorithm to run to it to work how
good you would solve this today you just
go and write 2 methods and what happened
when you have to do that for like 10
different use cases yeah you know it's a
it's maintenance nightmare if you care
if there's an error you had to actually
go to all the places to figure it out
so also if you can exploit the knowledge
of things that you know are constants
now it they may not be constant normally
but let's say ok page or page size for
us our page size is like this is a
constant but it can be a constant on
certain conditions and not on others so
we can actually play with this and still
use the same code and also it allows us
to avoid in variant conditionals which
which also are very good at the CPI
level that your run your real runtime
where the real meat happens so there's
and this is important there's not no
better branch predictor that do not
having to predict it doesn't it doesn't
matter how good you are to actually
figuring out a yeah you know in this
loop we are going always through these
particular disciplines to this
particular you still have to check and
you still have to go there in this way
you don't it just you're emitted the
actual code that you are need to execute
linearly so let's talk about this this
is what we are going to talk about is
the building blocks to actually measure
programming on c-sharp this is the
building blocks then you have to design
on top of it you have to build your
library of thinking that you're going to
use and use them in this way that's why
that's why I said when you go the road
of my grouped musician there's no coming
back
so let's let's think about it anyone
that has an you soon use the object pool
before anyone everybody used the object
pool then okay so essentially an object
pool is a allocations are a big problem
so we put all these allocations and
whatever whenever an object gets created
instead of like throwing it away for the
garbage collector to reclaim I just put
it someone else so if someone needs them
they just can't go and get and try to
get it from there first so let's say
that this is your object pool there are
the typical type of the out of the
object that you're going to store there
is T what the hell are the other two
saying hey what's the lifetime this is a
policy the typical policy that you will
find on addiction algorithms for
instance is this a policy what's the
lifetime look like for this object or
hey this is going to be run enough
thread aware on threaded coded or it is
going to be run away on single threaded
stuff this is the kind of markers that
we run in there so you're gonna have
actually have a single object pool where
you can actually say oh no no this is
gonna run on a thread on a
multi-threaded space so okay let's pay
for the cost oh no this is not going to
be run this is going to be single
threaded okay why I'm going to pay for
all the synchronization that can happen
we don't care so let's think about this
this is this is our pool this is our
pool we have an option pool T and we
also have like this default
implementation which is like okay this
is an alligator and in this is a lambda
is specifically and we have a non
threaded where behavior because okay we
are running this on single thread you
see there are defunct of P factory this
is the factory this is what we use to
actually create the object because if
you go in reflection I can tell you now
it's going to be bad so the interesting
thing about this is this this is an
object that doesn't exist this is an
object we decided that it has to exist
so as you see that object actually is
implemented I object life lifecycle what
it does hey it doesn't you nothing else
but there's something interesting here
hey this is not a class this is a struct
this is different this is treated
different by the just-in-time compiler
so let's see what's the difference in
here say okay we are going to run the
factory which is
our usual we are going to send over to
send out very alarmed expression and we
are going to use the one with the
function a locator you can see the
numbers we are talking half the cost if
you are allocating ten objects doesn't
matter but if you are allocating a
billion in a minute that's half the time
so in this case the difference the
actual difference is twenty seven in
assembly instructions and with 27
assembly instructions
you actually got half the time because
those instructions are the exact
instructions and no more that you need
for this specific task so let's talk up
about another use case this is anyone
anyone have been used in dictionary
before right it's like if you are not
using the dictionary you haven't code in
c-sharp
what dictionary are particularly bad
when you live when you have to define
objects which are user-defined why
because of compilers so we build our
first dictionary that actually has other
improvements but let's let's focus on
this particular thing which is you know
we are going to bake in the types the
policy for the compiler so just give me
a instruct here that implements I
equality compiler to actually call at
the moment that I need to compare stuff
the usual dictionary is high quality
compiler cheeky it's like I'm using the
interface instead of our particular our
particular implementation so how many
quality compared good look like let's
say that we have an equality compare for
long
equals and get high
code a asking asking the hashcode from
the lung which is not returning the same
lung important you are going to kill
your dictionary if uses over so who can
guess which is the slowest anyone I get
a 1 anyone wants to get the 2 how about
the 3 yeah yeah I any one of you have
seen this stuff before so yes we are
talking here about 19 microseconds
against the base implementation with you
see using so you can see that our
dictionary faster because of different
design choices but still when you go is
specific you can still have half the
time which means that if any of you
implemented dictionary as it is I'm
baking the sec the third type which is
the compiler you are probably going to
get half the time it doesn't much it
doesn't matter how much the Microsoft
implement a the Microsoft implemented
improves you can still improve more
because the cost of actually doing the
computation for a dictionary is high so
if you can omit exact code for that for
that comparison it's always gonna be
better period just to give you an idea
and because numbers you can actually
mess it this is this is an idea of how
different it is graphically we are
talking huge so just to give you an idea
these are actual numbers this is from an
actual workload you can you can actually
look that try get value and the gas hot
code and they are equal from the
dictionary are like absurd
and in this case this is a worst case
scenario because I actually had to call
compare in line which is a huge thing
because the
in time compiler didn't want such a big
method so it actually forces me to
actually call that method it decent it
did an honor their aggressive in line
which is also very important because I
mentioned in in very very deep in those
in those slides compiler directives are
hints they are not requirements so the
just-in-time I say no so this is on the
wild stuff this is like I got three
percent 3x improvement just doing this
if you are in the Sultan that means none
you are able to be three thousand your
throughput has just tripled if this is
your problem but let's go back to the
actual primitives let's go back to what
this talk is about this how do i craft
code that uses this kind of techniques
how do i know that the code that I am
actually writing is accessing this kind
of optimizations let's say that we have
this policy which is a simple one it's a
biksham you have seen it from any cache
server so it's in this case I decided to
just go very very very very simple I
said okay what you can never a big from
here or you can actually always a big
from here so this is a this is a
demonstration so let's say that we have
our cache and we are going to clear the
cache what will happen if I cannot a big
essentially what it will happen here is
let's look first at the code we are
going to ask hey can we a bit from here
no ok we are not the big thing
can we a big yes is this type this
possible then we are going to actually
dispose the object if not we don't care
we just clear
so in this simplification in this
simplified algorithm we can actually go
and look what happens when we call it
with different in different ways so
let's look at this so we have an int
that we're never going to be to evict we
have an object that we are always going
to be baked we have a disposable struct
that we are always known a big we have
an on disposable struct because
structure can also be this possible we
are that we are going to evict we also
have a class that we can show that we
are always gonna bake and there's always
an on disposable class that we are going
to did I miss anyone I think I think
this is the good matrix a if let me know
if I if I miss anyone okay so now let's
look at the interesting part which is
you actually go to the assembler code
after the release build and look at it
this is what we get
can anyone see any pattern I will make
it easy so we have a combination of
different of different types but it just
happened that hey you know there's
reader of they are equal what do they
have in common they are not structs they
are not value types because the runtime
is not able at least for now and I do
not say it to be hard to be happening
for at least a few years from now is not
able to be able to figure out that these
are different types of classes
everything gets collapsed to the same
code but hey on the other side we
actually see different course
so last let's inspect how those codes
look how that code looks like so we
started from this this is the end and
this is the never evict
so interesting thing about never big is
that it always returned false you
remember what happened with constants
they get propagated and you remember
what happened when something is false or
true so it's a constant the code gets
eliminated so this one this this is what
is important to us but it gets and it
ended up like looking like this it would
if we go if it don't trust me go to the
assembler and you will see this this is
our 138 version let's look to our
disposable stuff and we don't always
depict so we know we know for sure it
doesn't matter what we put on the first
one if we always use never bag we are
going to end up with the second the same
code period but in this case this this
case is interesting because we know we
are going from the top and then we are
going to end up in type of I disposable
it sustainable from type of T which I
used the which I didn't use the shirt
the shorthand version which is is type
of T I disposable that's that's a sure
had a shirt on - so the interesting
thing about here is okay well yeah we
have our our constant that we propagate
on top and we also have disposable type
of T where T is a struct okay this is
how we propagate this is the encode
anyone sees something fishy
what about the elves didn't go out we
cannot get rid of this branch so easily
because for some reason the just-in-time
compiler doesn't figure out that those
upper things is a constant that's why
going to the assembler is actually very
important when you are writing this kind
of code because you can end up in these
kind of situations so we are not going
we are going to say not today to this
one there's a way to get rid of this but
it's very convoluted but if we look at
this this is this this interesting look
at this
so we're essentially if we write the
other one that we are going to tell take
the other we are going to end on the
same code right but when we look at the
core it says hey it's actually different
and you know why because the struts are
different okay so while this is is
interesting in its own selves it means
that hey the the just-in-time compiler
is actually building it it's actually
building for the different strands the
different code for each one of those so
if I look at this and I see the type of
I disposable T is assignable from type
of T and it's not getting rid of it I
don't know in your country where I'm
come from where I come from this is the
pod so yes it's a very report I already
reported it so you can actually go to
github and actually vote for it so this
is at our first example this is how you
are actually doing coda specialization
this is an example of actual code
this is this is code that is running
live today if you are running Raven TV
what it does is says okay we have this
LC 4 compression algorithm which is
running entirely on c-sharp why because
if you go for for a person in C++ or
something which is faster it's not
because of interrupt this is actually as
fast as the c-sharp C++ version and I
can actually show that it's that it's
possible to actually write in C sharp so
fast code that you can actually rival
the assembly the hand-coded assembly web
version so in this case essentially what
we are saying is okay yes we have these
these markers that are going to optimize
in different ways and to do in different
ways with the with the data that comes
from there from the actual string of
data stream so if you are dealing with
like a 16 to a 16 in version we are
going to execute that code if we are
going if you gave me the 32 version we
are going to go to that code and if none
of those we are going to throw an
exception so you will know that you're
messing up with this and only the very
first part of this is going to be is
going to be put in the actual assembly
it's going to be emitted the other one
is going to get discarded now let's go
to a different building block this is
this is an entirely different it's more
or less it's more or less the same thing
but you are actually doing it
differently what you are saying is okay
yes I have this I managed write buffer
interface that has all these bunch of
methods so I create a nice truck for
each so I have an unmanaged stream
buffer and I have a manage write buffer
which aren't entirely different one is I
have the entire memory at hand and the
other one is I have a streaming version
of the of the memory at hand you can
actually say yes I can go manage to yes
I can build a managed version too if I
but interesting thing about this is that
this gets embedded into another sealed
class and because it gets embedded and
it because it is instruct whenever you
tell me a you know I want a blue double
writer that it's able to write to a
specific type of I - write buffer I'm
gonna meet a new little writer for its
particular type that you get mean so
whenever I call any method on this
particular on this particular little
writer I'm going to be guaranteed that
the code generation exonerated for that
class is going to be tailored for the
specific construct stop her the this
important think about it for a minute we
are saying hey we have classes and
classes by the run but the runtime they
don't get like did they get or put in
the same place right but in here we are
saying we are omitting even for a class
different versions of it tailored for
each use that we want you this is not a
method this is a class so I can go and
say okay I have this [ __ ] 4d object
pool and the way that I deal with the
object pool inside it just not no longer
a question of the how do I write I have
to write all the code for the different
behaviors no I write a fake ID which is
object pool and I implement how each one
of the operations is going to behave on
the strip himself so now every time that
I have a reference for this kind of
class
what I have is a natural reference to an
actual implementation that is
implemented this abotu spec this is an
this is an example we use right number
right number is different for each one
of the implementations and it's a very
very highly costly operation if you call
it now because we are using aggressive
inlining and all that the just-in-time
actually get like a huge method when I
when I do the writes and optimize the
layout of the code based on that so this
is another block this is a this is an
entirely different way of looking at the
same thing this is think about this
what's what's a page in a database a
page is like a chunk of memory of a
known time of unknown size that it also
has unknown header and all the different
things that you wanted a page to have
okay and we allocate pages like crazy
because hey I get pages like I can have
pages like a 4k so picture if you ax
asked me for something that is like a
megabyte but interesting thing here is
that you can actually hide that
complexity away because you can say okay
this is a page this is the Apple pointer
which is an index to somewhere and all
the methods actually get calls from the
backing store but this doesn't had to be
within managed memory you can have an
array of objects and instead of passing
integers
you can actually pass something that is
able to deal with all the complexity
that you are dealing with which becomes
an index so you can have an opaque
reference to any internal structure that
cost absolutely
nothing the actual runtime cast of this
thing is passing along over the stack so
the question that you may be asking
right now is this is worth the trouble
because if you I said if you are going
this road there's no going back
right this is optimizing the JSON parser
because hey we needed to optimize a JSON
parser and the problem was okay yes we
applied to something that is pretty
optimized but we are not able now to
deal with the bottlenecks like changing
how parsing is done or at the at the
next level which is okay we are dealing
with this we can change the actual
algorithm behind the person because in
the end parts in a symbol is an it's an
estate machine so in this case we
started this is when I took all these
it's almost three weeks ago it was
actually three weeks ago this is what it
from the internal Channel there hey we
are we were here now we're here so in
two weeks of applying these kind of
optimizations the beautiful writer was
one of those we went from that's around
500 seconds let's 6 minutes or something
even a little bit more to under three
minutes for a better base that's huge I
in just Jason
but then one week afterwards we were
already in almost su two minutes
I mean interesting thing is we were
trying because you remember that part of
the pareto is like 0.8 percent of the
code because I well I work in the 0.8 a
part of the code I wanted to I was
optimizing something else and this
happened because in the end I had to
optimize some little routine that
actually was used by the partial the
general offenders are always the same
when you are at that level of
performance and when you when you
already fix the stuff at the first level
and you already fix the stuff at the
second level the general offenders are
always the same
is it very same I can tell you like the
10 files that takes 80% of my time in a
year and I work always around those 10
files and it's friends in a
half-a-million software project so as
half a million lized
software plus you get idea ten fights
that only whiles means that I got a 6.6
X improvement in between the release and
a few weeks later in a patch release so
let's put all these together because I
think that this all this may look like
separated like this is this technique
and that technique actually that the
second level of this talk is actually
what are these the design tenants to
actually design libraries based on meta
programming concepts so in this case
what we're going to put it together to
try to try it we allow the specialized
generate code for specific conditions
the STL of c++ is exactly about that
it's about tailoring your code emission
specifically for the problem that you
have to solve also it allows us to
create for kids
four types that we know we cannot fix
the fire we kind of fix the problem at
this level because okay yes I'm going to
because everything depended on this
thing but what we can do is say okay we
are building a co cosmic aid on top of
this and every color is gonna tell me so
I the only thing that I have to do is go
to the caller and see okay how do you
want to use this oh you want this to use
this in this way in this way use this
parameter you go to the other color and
say okay and you want to use it so every
single one is going to get what he asked
for the general layout of the code
didn't change but the underlying emitted
assembly did change and it's way faster
because now it doesn't have to check hey
I needed to do this or I needed to do
that know that that question is never
there anymore you just go and you just
have only one path to go which is doing
the job that you were asked to do so for
anyone that comes from rust this is
essentially a constant the concept of
trade I trade or Co Co abstractions the
same if you come from C++ it's a
templates templates what the important
thing about templates if you think about
it is they are Turing complete this is
not the case at least not yet but there
is an interesting thing in this
institution
there's an interesting proposal at the
language level which is called shapes
and extensions if they ever implemented
Java and shapes and extensions they
could make the thing awesome because you
this is essentially the underlying
mechanics that we are doing by hand now
that will implement and give you the
ability to do this kind of stuff it also
these kind of techniques can be used to
the beautiful eyes while corsola the new
car CLR version from to 0 & 4 has the
ability to divert relies in some
specific cases for the difficult cases
that that just-in-time compiler is not
able to work with you can still use
these kind of techniques so if your
problem is how do I deal with verticals
that it can happen on highly efficient
code is you you go this route also
hiding pointers and references this is
big you can actually treat a pointer
what a manners reference that's the same
thing you don't need to know how it was
implemented this is like in the old
books say this I have an opaque
reference this is like the starting of
the type system theory is I have an
opaque reference I don't care what its
inside because I have the tools to
actually go and modify the state of that
reference without knowing what it's
bucking it you can actually also build
indexers and the cost of that
abstraction is a long an actual log on
the stack so it also allows you to avoid
lambda lambda context capture because if
you if you haba if you have an indexer
and that you can put on top you just
pass the index you just make sure that
you make that that information available
in some marking store which is the thing
that you are passing around through your
chain of methods your context and
because you are passing this interface
that behaves like like a long but
actually from the point of view of your
code is very meaty is a no pack
reference now the
of lambdas is essentially zero this kind
of things can actually cut down on your
allocations very hard and one final
thought this is this is general this is
not C sharp this is this is general if
you are working on code and you're
optimizing and you have people that is
optimizing your code one thing that I'd
like to like to say about optimizing
code if you are not doing you are
essentially burning money like old-style
burning money but whenever you start
your studies if if you are someone that
is new to the performance you're going
to go follow the route go off with the
bottlenecks if management says no to
higher risk no we had to reveal this
make sense okay let's go to the next
level if if the cost is still too high
or the risk is still too high then
figure out what are the worst places and
let's go and fix the let's figure out
where the 0.88 is but the problem is
that when you are done you are not done
and this is what I wanted to convey your
bottlenecks never ever go away they just
become more insidious because now what
you used to be a bottleneck and you fix
it like and in two months and you were
like hey this is great now your next
bottleneck is going to be an order of
magnitude complex so instead of two
months is really going to cost you six
or a year so what I mean here is when
you are arriving to the point that this
your software is actually efficient you
are going to end up dealing with stuff
like the memory model how this executed
on the CPU and that kind of stuff which
for some people like me is fun but for
most people is like where do
I want to quit but anyway so just to
give you an idea we are in the four zero
version and we already know that we have
to get get rid of our JSON parser which
is a state-based and about the bad news
is that the new course LR parser which
is going to be very fast it's not going
to cut it for us because it's still a
state machine we need to go to streaming
so we have to build it ourselves again
and the other one is our indexing engine
that we have been known for a fact that
it was a problem back in 3-0 by the way
from all the problems that we had it was
like okay yes I we have this building
rebuilding this will take us another two
years we are not going to delay so we
went for first for one and now we are
going for the other one but just to give
you an idea the entire data base
allocation budget for almost anything is
below 500 megabytes a single index in
run of Lezyne cost me 10 gigabytes so if
I if I if I take a like 10 minutes 10
minute for print of all the memory
allocations is like losing losing losing
losing losing losing losing Jason unlike
the tenth and if we are talking about
gigabyte gigabyte [ __ ] by [ __ ] [ __ ] 8
megabyte hey a hundred just to give you
an idea of how complex this thing become
a becomes thank you all for coming and
if we have some time we can have some
questions
[Applause]